since the advent of computers designing
complex machines and structures has
become way easier
computerized topology optimization can
simplify components of these modern
marvels even further reducing weight and
increasing efficiency but there's a
limit object sizes can't be very large
researchers at the Technical University
of Denmark have created a new software
tool that can visualize and optimize
complex shapes in high resolution just
as images on a computer screen are
broken up into pixels 3d images are made
up of boxes called voxels previous
computer design tools for this kind of
engineering could only generate designs
that were about 5 million voxels large
but with the giga voxel resolution of
the new system objects can be made up of
over 1 billion voxels so huge or highly
detailed objects can be optimized the
researchers say that their system scales
in both directions it can help optimize
massive engineering projects and smaller
nanoscale technologies the engineers put
the system through its paces by feeding
it a 27 meter long wing from a technical
model that resembles a Boeing triple7
airliner in a supercomputer crunched the
numbers for five days and produce a new
design a wing with a radical internal
structure that has kept solid through
curved wing spars and diagonal ribs the
new more hollow wing weighs 5% less than
the current Wings in use on the Boeing
triple7 such a reduction in weight means
the plane would consume up to 200 metric
tons less fuel per year but the wing
itself can be reasonably assembled
through any modern production process
however the researchers were able to
successfully 3d print a section of the
wing and new methods of additive
manufacturing could make fabricating
these designs easier in the future
you
[Music]
[Laughter]